Wow this is bright let's use a lot of
power
well flying you all in here must have
cost a bit of energy too so the whole
planet needs a lot of energy and so far
we've been running mostly on fossil fuel
we've been burning gas been a good run
it get us to where we are but we have to
stop we can't do that anymore
so we are trying different type of
energy now alternative energy but it
proved quite difficult to find something
that's as convenient and as
cost-effective as oil gas and coal my
personal favorite is nuclear energy now
it's very energy dense it produced solid
reliable power and it doesn't make any
co2 now we know of to way of making
nuclear energy fission and fusion now in
fission you take a big nucleus you break
it in part in tube and make lots of
energy this is all the nuclear reactor
today works works pretty good
and then there's fusion now I like
fusion fusion is much better so you take
two small nucleus you put it together
and you make ilium and that's very nice
makes lots of energy this is nature way
of producing energy the Sun and all the
stars in the universe run on fusion now
a fusion plant would actually be quite
cost-effective and it also would be
quite safe it only produce short-term
radioactive waste and it cannot meltdown
now the fuel from fusion comes from the
ocean the ocean you can extract the fuel
for about one thousandth of a cents per
kilowatt hour so that's very very cheap
and if the whole planet would run on
fusion it would run we could extract the
fuel from the ocean it would run for
billions and billions of year now
infusion is so great why don't we have
it where is it well there's always a bit
of a catch Fusion is really really hard
to do so the problem is those two
nucleus they're both positively charged
so they don't they don't want to fuse
they go like this they go like that
so in order to make them fuse you have
to throw them at each other with great
speed and if they have enough speed it
will go against the repulsion it will
touch and they only make energy now the
particle speed is a measure of the
temperature so the temperature required
for fusion is 150 million degrees C this
is rather warm and this is why Fusion is
so hard to do now I cut my little fusion
bug when I did my PhD here the
University of British Columbia and then
I get a big job in laser printer place
making printing for the printing
industry I worked there for you know ten
years and I got a little bit bored and
then I was 40 and I got to middle life
crisis you know the usual thing Who am I
what should i do what should I do what
can I do and then I was looking at my
good work and what I was doing is I was
cutting the forests around here in BC
and burying you all of you in millions
of tons of junk mail now that was not
very satisfactory so some people buy a
Porsche other you know get a mistress
but I've decided to get my bit to sell
solve global warming and make fusion
happen now so the first thing I did is I
look into the literature and I see all
those fusion work so the physicists have
been working on fusion for a while and
one of the way to do it is with
something called a tokamak it's a big
ring of magnetic coil superconducting
coil and makes a magnetic field you know
in a string like this and the hot gas in
the middle which is called a plasma is
trapped the particle go round and round
and round the circle and the wall then
they draw huge amount of heat in there
to try to cook that to fusion
temperature so this is the inside of one
of those donut and on the right side you
can see the fusion plasma in there now
second way of doing this is by using
laser fusion now in laser fusion you
have a little ping-pong ball
you put the fusion fuel in the center
and you zap that with all bunch of laser
around it the laser are very strong and
it squashed a big ball ball really
really quick and if you squeeze
something hard enough it gets hotter and
if it get really really fast and they do
that in one billionth of a second it
make enough energy and enough heat to
make few
so this is the inside of one such
machine you see the laser beam and the
pellet in the center now most people
think that fusion is going nowhere
they always think that the physicists
are in their lab and they're working
hard but nothing is happening that's
actually not quite true this is a curve
of the gain in fusion over the last 30
years or so and you can see that we're
making now about ten thousand times more
fusion that we used to when we started
that's pretty good gain as a factor of
fact it's as fast at the Fable Moore's
Law that define the amount of transistor
you can put on a chip now this dot here
is called jet the joint or a foreign
tourist it's a big tokamak doughnut in
Europe and this machine in 1997 produced
16 megawatt of fusion power with 17
megawatt of heat now you see that's not
much useful but it's actually pretty
close considering we can get about
10,000 times more than we started the
second dot here is the NIF it's the
national initiative it's a big laser
machine in the US and last months they
announced that with quite a bit of noise
the D managed to make more fusion energy
from the diffusion that the energy that
they put in the center a ping-pong ball
now that's not quite good enough because
the laser to put that energy in was more
energy than that but it's pretty good
now this is ETA pronounced in French ETA
so this is a big collaboration of
different countries that are building a
huge magnetic doughnut in the South of
France and this machine when it's
finished will produce 500 megawatts of
fusion power with only 50 megawatt to
make it so this one is the real one it's
gonna work that's gonna machine that
makes energy now if you look at the
graph you will notice that those two
dots a little bit on the right of the
curve we kind of have fallen off the
progress actually the science to make
those machine was really in time to
produce fusion during that curve however
there's been a bit of politic going on
and the will to do it was not there so
it drifted to the right eater for
example could have been built in 2000 or
2005 but because it's a big
international collaboration the politic
got sinned and it delayed it a bit for
example you take them about three years
to decide where to put it
now Fusion is often criticized for being
a little too expensive yes indeed costs
you know a billion dollar or two billion
dollar a year to make this progress but
you have to compare that to the costs of
making the Moore's law that costs way
more than that the result of the moolah
is this cell phone here in my pocket
this cell phone and the internet behind
it cost about one trillion dollars just
so I can take a selfie and put it on
Facebook then when my dad see that he'll
be very proud we also spend about 650
billion dollar a year in subsidies for
oil and gas and renewable energy now we
spend one half of a percent of that on
fusion so me personally I don't think
it's too expensive I think it's actually
been shortchanged considering it can
serve all those energy problems cleanly
for the next couple of billions of years
now I can say that but I'm a little bit
biased because I started a fusion
company and I don't even have a Facebook
account so so when I started this fusion
company in 2002 I knew I couldn't fight
with the big labs they had much more
resources than me
so I decided I need to find a solution
that is cheaper and faster now magnetic
and laser fusion a pretty good machine
they are some piece of technology
wonderful machine and they have shown
that fusion can be done however as a
power plant I don't think they are very
good they read too big way too
complicated way too expensive and also
they don't deal very much with the
fusion energy when you make fusion the
energy come out as Neutron fast Neutron
comes out of the plasma those Neutron
hit the wall of the Machine it damages
it and also you have to catch the heat
from those Neutron run some steam to
spin a turbine somewhere and on those
machine it was all a bit of an
afterthought so I decided that sure late
is a better way of doing that so back to
the literature and I read about the
fusion everywhere one way in particular
we attract my attention and it's called
magnetized target fusion or MTF for
short now in MTF what you want to do is
you take a big vat and you feel that
with liquid metal and you spin the
liquid metal to obtain a vortex in the
center you know a bit like your sink
when you pull the plug on a sink it
makes a vortex and then you have some
piston driven by pressure that goes on
the outside and this compress the liquid
metal around the plasma and it compress
it gets hotter like laser and then it
makes fusion so it's a bit of a mix
between a magnetized fusion and the
laser fusion so dos have a couple of
very good advantage the liquid metal
absorb all the neutrons and no neutrons
hit the wall and therefore there's no
damage to the machine the liquid metal
gets hot so you can pump that in the
heat exchanger make some steamed spinach
turbine so that's really convenient way
of doing this part of the process and
finally all the energy to make the
fusion happen come from steam power
piston which is way cheaper than laser
or superconducting coil now this was all
very good except for the problem that it
didn't quite work so we the catch so
when you compress that the plasma cool
down faster than the compression speed
so you're trying to compress it but the
plasma cool down and cool down and cool
down and then it did absolutely nothing
so when I saw that I say well this is
such a shame because it's a very very
good idea so awfully I can improve on
that so I thought about it for a minute
and I say ok how can we make that works
better so then I talked about impact
what about we use a big hammer and we
swing it and we hit that the nail like
this in place of putting the hammer on
the nail and pushing and trying to put
it in that that won't work so what the
idea is is to use the idea of an impact
so we accelerate the piston which steam
that takes a little bit of time but then
bang and hit the piston and pass all the
energy is done instantly download
instantly into the liquid and that
compress the plasma much faster so I
decide ok this is good let's make that
so we build this machine in this garage
here we've make a small machine that we
managed to squeeze a little bit of
Neutron out of that and those are my
marketing Neutron and Windows marketing
Neutron then I raise about 50 million
dollar and I hire a 65 people that's my
team here and this is what we want to
build so it's going to be a big machine
about 3 meter in the emitter
liquid LED spinning around big vortex in
the center put the plasma on the top and
on the bottom
piston hit on the side bang it
compresses it and it will make some
energy the neutron will come out in the
liquid metal going
new steam engine and make the turbine
and some of the steam would go back to
fire the piston we're gonna run that
about one time per second and this will
produce how to make a watt of
electricity okay we also build this
injector so this injector makes the
plasma to start with
it makes the plasma about lukewarm
temperature of 3 million degrees C
unforce lead doesn't last quite long
enough so we need to extend the life of
the plasma a little bit but last month
it got a lot better so I think we have
the plasma was compressing now then we
build a small sphere but this big 14
piston around it and this will compress
the liquid
however plasma is difficult to compress
when you compress it it tends to go a
little bit crooked like that so you need
the timing of the piston to be very good
and for that we use several control
system which was not possible in 1970
but we now can do that with a nice new
electronic so finally most people think
that fusion is in the future and will
never happen but as a matter of fact
fusion is getting very close we almost
there the big lab of showed that fusion
is doable and now the small company that
are thinking about that and you see it's
not that it cannot be done but it's all
to make it cost-effectively
general fusion is one of those small
company and hopefully very soon somebody
someone will crack that nut and perhaps
will be general fusion thank you very
much
[Applause]